welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy whose
breakdowns you watch whilst you wait for
new rock stars to upload theirs
and this video we have a lot to talk
about episode 7 of one division
brings heaps with it and we pick up in
the aftermath of wonder expanding the
hex
after she lost her vision like daredevil
the malcolm in the middle esque entry
had visions saying
you're not the boss of me now and the
cliffhanger showed sword for the clowns
they really are
episode 7 evolves the two storylines in
many ways
and there's a lot to unpack from the
entry as always i'm going to be
discussing
more of the general aspects of the
episode up top but if you want to speed
through the video then the time codes
are linked below
now firstly i want to go over billy and
tommy which just so happens to be the
name of both my grandfathers
it's all connected it's clear that the
characters are becoming wicked in speed
and thus i feel like this is the best
video to give you the 4-1-1 on who they
really are
originally in the comics the twins were
introduced as wander's children in the
graphic novel vision and the scarlet
witch
this book followed the pair as they made
a life in new jersey
but there was a twist in the tale
because vision was unable to have
children
wander unwittingly used fragments of
mephisto's soul
to give life to them and they were
eventually reabsorbed by the villain
however the pair were eventually brought
back and they were reincarnated under
surrogate parents to become the mutants
that we all know and love
because vision can't have kids and
they're technically blood relatives to
different people
the comic book counterparts aren't
really wonders children
but they are at the same time the weird
outline of the family tree
might even be upping the ante when
compared to something as complicated as
game of thrones
and that had moments where jon snow was
up in the ante hey
now i kind of feel like this show could
potentially just combine these two
arcs skip over the devil in the details
and give us a more streamlined story
as the weeks have gone on i've grown
slightly less confident that mephisto is
the villain
and it raises less questions by just
having them remain as her kids by birth
the pair are the first two naturally
born superheroes in the mcu
and it is likely that they will open the
door for other quote-unquote mutants to
come down the line
when it comes to their powers they
possess pretty much the exact same skill
set as scarlet witch in quicksilver
to paraphrase maria hill and age of
ultron speeds fast and he's weird
unlike their mother and uncle though
they also have some unique abilities
though they can't beat box as well as
wanda can now speed can actually alter
the kinetic energy of objects through
using his touch
some of the gambit of the x-men this
causes them to vibrate and overheat
and thus eventually they explode like
wonder
wicken can fire energy bolts and he also
has the ability to read minds he's
definitely the one to look out for
and amongst the magic community he is
highly regarded
dr strange has even predicted that one
day he will grow up to become the most
powerful superhero in the universe
and with this in mind it makes sense as
to why the pair are so so after in west
view
now they are both members of the young
avengers and with hailee steinfeld
playing kate bishop
it seems that the studio are setting the
team up i want to another key character
and that is agatha harkness who caused a
lot of aggro
as agnes though we've touched upon her
and some of the breakdowns so far
i thought we'd ag another look so you
can understand her comic book roots
and the way that marvel originally set
her up her terrible puns now agatha was
born circa 11 000 bc
and after having contact with a cosmic
being known as scryer
she slowly made her way through the
world mastering her magical abilities
by the 17th century she'd come to settle
amongst
an english colony in salem america and
amongst them
she formed a coven of witches the
puritans of the time tried to uproot
them
and conducted the salem witch trials
which she of course survived
shortly after she settled into the town
of new salem a made-up magical community
in the marvel universe
as its strongest sorceress she became
the leader and actually had an
evil warlock child known as nicholas
scratch which was probably referenced in
agnes rabbit's signor scratchy
which also happens to be a nickname for
the devil after the second world war
agatha joined the us army and stopped
being held up on hate
and shortly after she posed as a nanny
and started working for sue and reed
richards
in order to keep an eye on their baby
franklin eventually agatha was captured
by the salem 7
and taken back to new salem where she
was burned at the stake
wonder went toe to toe with them and not
long after she fell
pregnant agatha's spirit appeared to her
on halloween when the barrier between
worlds was at its thinnest
and later she manifested to reveal the
truth about her babies
though an eventual mentor to wonder
wonder actually ended up killing her
and since then the characters sort of
drifted back and forth between appearing
in certain arcs
now as for episode 7 this entry pulls
heavily from shows like modern family
and the office
we watched as the series has mimicked
sitcoms set in the decades
and this one some more expertly
recaptures the aesthetic of the shows
that they're raping
over the series we pretty much watched
marvel also chronicle the evolution of
the sitcom
and have witnessed how these changed
from very standard shows to ones that
then broke the fourth wall
this idea of allowing characters to talk
directly to the audience
was then brought very much into the plot
itself and both the office and modern
family were presented as documentaries
unlike the other episodes we get to see
wonder and visions in her thoughts
through this
and it displays a lot about their
characters kind of hope that we
eventually get more decades down the
line and hopefully we will see professor
x
showing up in the 2020s decade like this
cut to wonder waking up and remembering
the morning after the night before
we've all been their love once i watched
justice league
now she explains how her fear and anger
got the best of her
and also waves her hand in emotion
similar to how she casts a spell
showcasing that this is what she tends
to do when she's backed into a corner
the hex itself is very much built upon
the anguish of the character
and thus her doing this shows how she
prefers to magic her problems away
instead of tackling them head on tommy
and billy enter the room
and we can see that they are wearing the
colours that are typically associated
with their comic book counterparts
speed of course wears green and wiccan
wears red blue and black
they talk about how their game
controllers have been flipping through
time
and shout outs kid for commenting on my
last video that when wonder expanded the
hex
there was also a mixture of the decades
this losing the control
of the controllers shows that she's lost
control
puns there and in pop some gamecube ones
some from the atari
before they finally switch to uno cards
billy says that his head feels weird
and as we learned last episode the
character has psychic abilities
that are likely picking up all of the
extra people that wanders brought into
the domain
wonders says that she's planning on
taking a quarantine staycation and
whoa love too soon that too soon
now some interesting things in this
scene are that the duvet
and visions pillow are both covered in
hexagons
however wonders pillow isn't likely
showcasing that she's not subject to the
same things that he and the rest of the
town are
hexagons have of course appeared
throughout the show and in nature they
also appear in beehives
namely because of the shape of
honeycombs in preparation for this
series i reread some of the classic
storylines that led into house of m
including avengers disassembled which
featured a queen bee character
named adriana soria the queen was able
to control her subjects through a hive
mind
and this is very similar to how wanda is
able to alter the actions and memories
of those around her
though the characters are different i
did find it interesting how the graphic
novel set at the events of house of m
which this show is based upon and it too
used the imagery of hexagons throughout
the duvet and pillow also contain
hexagons within hexagons
cementing the expansion of the hex and
how it has started to encompass more
things
which wonder clearly regrets another
interesting thing is that wonder says
we built a hex not i this highlights the
end reveal in that it's been
agatha all along now wonder goes down
the stairs in a shot that very much apes
the one from last week
perhaps this shows how the decades are
starting to become interchangeable
and i love how they kind of mimic the
cinematography here to push for that
idea
she starts to have some cereal and we
notice as the milk changes
there's actually a missing child's
poster on one version of it
and as we know there are kids slowly
starting to disappear
however if we line this show up with the
behind the scenes images of spider-man 3
it looks like there's also kids missing
in that too perhaps
agnes ends up doing this to kids on a
grand scale and this may be how the
properties are interlinked
there's also a maze on the back of the
sugar snaps which could be a nod to how
the show is basically all of the
characters trying to navigate this thing
that they've been pulled into
there's a purple elephant on it and the
phrase an elephant never forgets
very much juxtaposes how those inside
the hex have been stripped of their
memory i'm sorry that's a reach that's
that's a big reach now
the intro is very much in the vein of
the office down to its theme tune
and we see the words wonder flash on
screen this shows that she is alone and
it's
only at the end that vision comes in now
an interesting detail that pops up is
that it says created by wonder maximoff
i still believe that one to create the
hex himself and the person that pushed
her into doing it
was agnes or rather agatha aguetta could
be draining the life force from her
and this might be why the yo magic
commercial showed someone starving to
death
whilst focusing on a smaller problem
either way we cut to the temporary sword
retreat
and see that the hex is now covering a
wide area very much in an under the dome
style
hayward says they launched today and
it's likely that he's planning an
all-out assault for episode 9. now i say
9 because
i think next week's will be a flashback
and the one following it will be the
culmination of the reveal at the end of
this one
we then cut it inside the hex and see
vision waking up
hayward's henchman is now a strong man
and darcy is an escape artist
she was sucked in whilst tied to a car
wearing handcuffs
and thus this lines up with what she is
doing on the outside world
and it's a detail i appreciate at
wonders she tells the kids that she
doesn't have the answers
and fell a lot like i did until the last
three minutes of this episode
she believes that everything is
meaningless but there are of course
dark forces working behind the scenes
likely trying to weaponize her kids
because of their powers
agatha walks in and the first hint we
get that she's an alternate character
is her purple shirt which is a color of
agatha in the comics
she also asks wanda to look at her mole
and shout out
andrew nicholson on twitter for pointing
out that this is typically the mark of a
witch
she takes the kids with her and slowly
the room starts to jump through the time
periods
with the fireplace that was present in
episode 1 now making a return jump to
jimmy and monica
and they discussed the cataract project
as we predicted
heywood was trying to weaponize vision
but he was unable to bring him back
online
last week hinted to us that times got
desperate during the five-year period
between the snap and blip
and likely because of the fear that was
right throughout the world he turned
back to trying to recreate ultron or a
defense program of the same elk
now when we saw wonder at the end of end
game she seemed to be accepting a
vision's death
however it is possible that when she
learned he was being turned into a
weapon
that she completely snapped vision
doesn't have the same rights as a human
judah being a synthesized and she would
have no control over what happened to
his body
this is likely why she broke into sword
and as it's a crying to go against a law
enforcement agency
the character had to go on the run now
monica arrives and meets her friends
namely major goodness now though this
was a slightly disappointing reveal i
don't actually believe that this is the
aerospace engineer and
i think that they'll probably come in
towards the end of the series and thus
the endless speculation continues back
at the circus we watch his vision tries
to awaken darcy
and see a sign saying fool the guesser
which i think is the showrunners making
fun of us
for doing non-stop fan theory videos and
getting them all wrong
well i did get the agnes thing to be
fair i knew i did i did a big video on
it
anyway after a brief stop by wonders
where reality is falling apart
we jump to the commercial the woman from
the other ones is back
and in this she clearly represents
wonder so far
every ad has pulled from a trauma in her
past and this is clearly the grief she
felt over the death of vision
the character sits alone on a bench and
this is very much in the same way that
wonder would have been
at the end of endgame like the start of
the episode she also lies in a bed by
herself
and the antidepressant nexus is
mentioned now this has a number of
things going on with it
and the first thing that we should focus
on is the word nexus
in age of ultron this was categorized as
the central hub
where all information on the internet
flows through however in marvel comics
it goes far beyond that wander is
actually what's known as the nexus being
and this means that she's someone who is
exactly the same across all dimensions
in the multiverse
nexus beings are keystones of existence
and they have the ability to affect
probability
and therefore the future if our theories
are right about these things being
linked to the infinity stones
though we might actually have somewhat
of a double up here so far we've seen a
toaster that looked similar to vision
due to its face layout vision was
nicknamed toaster in the comics
and thus if this is true we can assume
that the light in the middle of it
is the mind stone the watch dealt with
time like the time stone
and the hydra soap box look like the
tesseract the lagos red liquid was
similar to the reality stone
and due to yo magic dealing with death
it could also be the soul stone
now this nexus advert two centers around
reality
and it may be because of the stone's
multiple states that it's appeared twice
maybe we got the lagos one wrong though
and it was actually the power stone
but obviously let me know your thoughts
below now the plot to kidnap the
children
could be a skull at herring itself and
the infinity stones being recreated may
also be the main objective in the show
we know that they are paramount to
keeping all of reality stable
and thus their recreation is very
important as it stops the main timeline
from traveling down a dark path
in the trailers we have seen what looks
like it could be the mind of soul stone
along with what may be the tesseract but
obviously we won't find that out for
definite until we have all of the
episodes together
kurta agnes house and i just want to
shout out jeff barbos on twitter for
pointing out that this is actually the
same home from bewitched
further pointing towards the end reveal
agatha sits down with the two on the
sofa
along with senor scratchy wiccan isn't
able to read her
mind because she's empty and this could
actually highlight that she may be
possessed too
potentially by nightmare or mephisto yes
we're still we're still going with the
mephisto thing
the reason i think this is because she
was a good character in the comics for
the most of it
and i definitely think that the basement
and post-credits scene highlights that
there are more people involved
we still haven't seen the enigmatic
ralph yet and i believe that they might
actually be the big bad behind it all
good to the outside of the hex and
monica trying to re-enter it
this initially doesn't go according to
plan but the last never learns
and decides to stick a face in it once
more now
saying that though i absolutely love
this scene and it's one of the
highlights in this show for me so far
the transformations are absolutely
incredible
and seeing her finally become photon i
just found
fascinating if you want a full breakdown
on the character then check out our last
episode
but i think we can now fully confirm
that they are one and the same because
of the similarities in uniform
in the background we can also hear audio
clips from captain marvel
and these are namely quotes from carol
and her mother which show that we all
have the ability
to be a hero now monica actually sees
radio waves within the hex
and it is possible that these towers are
what's broadcasting the signal
i'm not 100 on that as for god's sakes
i'm an easter egg hunter
not a radio engineer now on the road
dorsey recounts the truth of what
happened division to him
whilst they get stopped by some
distractions in this conversation
i realized that vision has never really
had any choice
or agency in his life jarvis was created
by tony to be a servant
and he was then put into a body by
ultron to be a weapon of mass
destruction
sword wanted to use him for their own
means and now wanda keeps him around
just to keep her happy the guy doesn't
really have any choice in this world
i feel like this show will very much be
about him gaining his independence
whilst others still want to use him for
their own means
i also kind of feel like these
quote-unquote roadblocks were put in
place by agatha
as whenever someone has got close to the
truth she's made them deviate from the
path in some way
thus i feel like this has been done to
accomplish that year and whatever our
end goal is
she definitely wants to keep the hex
going now monica finally arrives at
wonders
and we see her wearing a scarlet hoodie
similar to her costume
monica tries to tell her about hayward's
plan and wonder makes her levitate
but she comes down with a superhero
landing
they all bloody do it now the
neighborhood stop and watch and we see
that they are pretty much
fixated on wanderer monica they could
all be servants for agatha at this point
and i'm not writing anything off i know
you're watching dottie i know it's you
the moniker knows that wonder is a good
person deep down and that she won't kill
her
and it's only upon agatha's arrival that
she's unable to get through to her
agatha takes her to her home and vision
tired of waiting by all these truman
show level-esque distractions
decides to fly to wonder himself inside
agatha's home she realizes that
something is wrong
likely because reality here is
stabilized she also notices a fly on the
curtain
and i don't know if i'm reading too much
into it but the green on it reminded me
a lot of nightmare
as i said earlier i think there's more
than meets the eye and that a bigger bad
will be teased before being fully
revealed to go forward
as a staple villain similar to what
thanos was wonder notices the twins food
is half-eaten
and this is potentially because they
were drugged the glasses
also have hexagons in the middle of the
star pattern tying back to the way that
the world is built
in the basement wonder sees an ancient
cavern covered in roots and tree
branches
and she travels into it which is when
the aspect ratio changes
showing that this is the real world
there's a sect here similar to a coven
and also what i believe is the dark hold
the darkhold is an ancient book of
spells
that has appeared throughout the comics
agents of shield
and a lot more the only reason i'm
questioning whether it is or not is
because the design is different but i
believe that it would be something that
agatha would possess
and it could also showcase how the
reality was created
agatha comes in and reveals the truth
and she says that wander isn't the only
magical girl in town
i'm looking at you dottie now it could
be possible that the entire woman's
meeting from episode 2 was
actually all of the witches and west
view who had come together
this would be a reveal at titan with the
source material
though that might be a reach and i know
geraldine isn't a witch yes before you
start commenting
now agatha is stroking senor scratchy
and this is similar to how she carries
her cat ebony in the comics
i think they switched it to a rabbit so
the reveal wasn't too obvious
but in the source material that animal
actually has the ability to change into
a large black panther
her broaches also reappeared and it's
likely that this is
actually the key to her powers we then
see things from agatha's perspective
and get a hilarious twist on the
monster's theme tune
which shows things from her perspective
as she messes with people
now there is a moment amongst this where
we see her magic against evan peters's
back
in the power's credit scene when monika
is snooping around he appears and seems
to be like a villain
however i think that this is just a hint
to us that she is actually controlling
him
and that he probably will be a good guy
a lot of people have theorized that
quicksilver could actually be mephisto
or nightmare in disguise
and this was given further credence by
the character's name appearing in
quotation marks on his funko pop
however i think this is because in the
fox universe he was known as peter
and the quotation marks are likely
because he's now playing pietro
which we know is a recast joke the
halloween episode also showed the
characters in the costumes that they
wear in the comics
and thus we can take it that these are
their true versions
his appearance in the post-credits scene
also has the blue and white
so i'm not fully convinced that he's an
evil guy agatha doing this to him at the
door
to me at least cements that he's not in
control of it
and i know she's a bad woman because she
killed sparky his son of a [ __ ]
now as mentioned the post-credits scene
contains moniker making it to agatha's
house
and finding the entrance to the basement
quicksilver arrives and likely captures
her
however we know that vision is going
there too and thus we can take it that
he will free them
and potentially also knock evan peters
out of it
i hope so anyway please don't be bad
yeah i want the x-men i want you jackman
back
now before we get into my review of
episode 7 and the news of a jimmy wu
show i really appreciate it if you gave
this video a thumbs up and also make
sure you subscribe to the channel
so you don't miss our breakdowns on the
last two episodes as for the show itself
i'm absolutely in love with the series
at this point
not since westworld have i been so
captivated by the mysteries behind the
season
and though seeing that please standby
sign at the end of every episode
sucks the next episode is always with
the week-long wait
though i liked scarlet witch invasion in
the comics the pair were never really my
favorite
but similar to what marvel have done
with captain america and iron man
they've managed to move these c-listers
up to be major stars
they've arguably got one of the most
fascinating arcs in the entire mcu
and week after week i can't wait to see
what happens i've actually gone back and
watched all of the episodes about four
times now
and even though i wasn't too hot on the
opening too with the added context of
what we now have
i think they're a lot better this was
another excellent entry
and as they slowly start to pull back
the curtain on the show
i'm really enjoying it more and more now
this is normally the part of the video
where i talk about leaks but there's not
really been that many this week
so i thought i'd focus on teasers
towards a show that we might be getting
down the line also i just want to thank
each and every one of you for getting
the videos trending five weeks in a row
my dad has finally started calling me
sun instead of trash bag
and it's really helped with my
self-esteem also it looks like we might
be seeing more of jimmy woo
after the show ends as steven ford
teased on twitter that his disney plus
spin-off series
might have been greenlit he still hasn't
offered confirmation yet
but he did post a picture of his brown
and black xbox controller in front of
what looks like agency documents for the
character
ford is the mind behind teen wolf and
there is potential that he's been
working with disney plus
in order to push this idea forward it
looks like park's head has been
superimposed onto daniel craig's james
bond one
i think it would be great if marvel took
this idea of a secret agent
and applied it to jimmy it also opens
the door for things like agents of atlas
a group which jimmy was a member of and
potentially we could see their formation
in the mcu
now i'm not by any means saying that
this is a definite and ford himself
could just be trying to build hype
around his show that he's pitching
however jimmy is such a popular
character and if they were gonna do
something with him
i think that this would be one of the
best avenues anyway that's the video
and i'd obviously love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with us
you'll be entered into a prize draw on
the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
the links to our socials are in the
description
and you can also support the channel by
clicking the join button and as a thank
you you get videos like this early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
all the theories around agnes
and why we thought she was faking it
we've also covered every episode of the
series so far so if you missed one of
them then they'll be linked on screen
right now
without the way thank you for sitting
through this i've been paul and i'll see
you next time
take care peace
you